we are amazing welcome to to the Polish
state YouTube live I'm Justin e Peterson
apologize for the late start but we are
black everybody people are late we start
on CP time I'm glad you're here you love
me I don't really know you do you have
to know me to love me yeah well I love
you thank you
are you surprised not really were you
surprised that I threw you off to radio
show not really
and one of the reasons I'm concerned
about you being a progressive is that
and he specifically are all progressive
all men men only men only men
progressive women that don't concern is
it's normal normal abnormal for women to
be progressive interesting liberal but
it's abnormal for a man to be a liberal
or progressive it's a sign of being a
beta male I didn't know how real men are
conservative no if I became conservative
would I no longer be beta you'd become
alpha well something to think about
do you find that it's difficult for
young men merely your age group to find
good women to date not at all
why don't you date men I'm not attracted
to men oh good
what would you consider it might be a
man what do you think of it as a man
it's what I think of it as a man right
it's a person right I don't say well
it's a female the children are allowed
at liberal media the Democratic Party oh
the Rhino Republicans they're never
trappers okay there's no like everybody
but Trump this movement please now I
know mentally off you know right like
the life was all but nobody was home
you're making assessments of who's
mentally off on TV but that's how even
the children are the left are they'll
destroy you to get what they want and
that's power and well I'm curious if
they're so powerful the children of
though they're not powerful oh I think
that's what they want I think we will
destroy it they will they'll destroy you
they were try to do so okay do you get
power do you agree with that no no the
reason was you've called me a girly man
so many times that we talk about weak oh
okay that's because it's not because I
think you that I'm gay right got it
glad we clarified you know a lot of
people are sexually assaulted and raped
and they don't come forward
and the reason I don't event you don't
believe that's a made-up lighter oh who
made that up the children are the laugh
I should I'm sure another last shittin
ya doing it because they hate men oh and
they especially hate three white
conservative Christian men of power if
it wasn't for them America would be
associated a society already it would be
what a socialist society by getting rid
of jobs many people mostly took care of
people backing away the few time jobs
and they had to work two part-time jobs
in order to survive Justin you don't
even understand the talking points
resting three Obama Falls
that's socialist socialism but you're
not answering a question that's the
answer but I don't like the answer you
don't understand a question I think I
understand it when what is it about the
questions that's difficult for you do
you would you gave it Patman believe it
just because she said I liked how you
had to check what like my last name was
there I would believe it enough to
investigate it yeah give me the thing
yes I'm black and follow so give me a
simple yes or no your friends are
watching right now I hope so and they're
watching because they thought you gonna
keep my book so you got to live up to it
I found out this was a debate today
are these really the most important
topics for you absolutely okay how are
there others that are more important for
you yeah our economic system wealth
inequality health care of your politics
nuclear disarmament climate change and
the black people go into a trance and
then going in and yeah yeah they reach
for the D Y eating chicken I guarantee
you if they went now and voted for and
asked them to vote for they would go
with the homosexuals I hope so Andhra
Democratic Party hopes they have been
morally bankrupt well I just radical
homosexual or some guy in there and they
corrupted churches anything else not
that I can think of that's it yeah
amazing people come from [ __ ]
countries and we don't have no idea who
crossing the borders we could have been
lighting folks coming I think we just
disagree amazing um
it's crazy to disagree isn't is that a
good thing that the president has done
what do you do bring a jobs how
about how he's brought them back is that
a good thing if you're going to claim he
did it you have to explain how is that a
good thing you don't happen because
there are two their jobs the question is
what did he do to bring the job well
what he did is they were good to
identify what he did I just told you man
how do you know he did it it's a good
thing that he did it
jobs are good I'm asking you what Trump
did you think yesterday
what is the man I'm sorry what is the
man I do politics not dictionary are you
a man love what is love
I don't do the dictionary definitions I
won't be doing dictionary definitions at
any of my events that's the one thing if
people are expecting that I'm not doing
any dictionary definitions the [ __ ]
feel amazing incredible you like [ __ ]
I'm sorry
you like let's I don't know any have you
ever say that word of [ __ ] I don't think
so would you date or fled
it's a pejorative it's not a term I use
amazing did you have fun no in in a
thousand years when the sociologists and
the Philosopher's try to figure out what
exactly happened in the United States
are right around this time this type of
conversation is going to be incredibly
informative for them so I'm glad to have
participated in it good man I think only
thing well jesse was amazing check out
our brand-new saw on the jessamine
peterson comm on my instagram you're
doing songs now huh Facebook Twitter you
sing are you playing in beta male you
know what a beta male is no check out
the song chase Trump right alpha naught
beta see him with the toilet paper on
his shoe super alpha move huh I didn't
see it huh thank you all thank you do
thank you